[Música]
rusia utiliza los alimentos como un arma
contra ucrania así lo denunció el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken él afirmó que las tropas rusas
tienen como rehenes a los suministros e
impiden las exportaciones de granos por
otro lado el senado estadounidense
aprobó un nuevo paquete por 40 mil
millones de dólares para ucrania
varios países de europa y eeuu han
reportado casos de la llamada viruela
del mono aunque es poco infecciosa entre
humanos hay alerta en la comunidad
internacional en esta emisión les
contamos de qué se trata este días
37 años tuvieron que esperar los
familiares de las víctimas de la masacre
accomarca el perú para recibir los
restos de sus seres queridos esta es una
de las matanzas más recordadas en el
país en la que los militares mataron a
71 personas en 1985 después de acusar
las falsamente de pertenecer al grupo
armado sendero luminoso
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle empezamos
en eeuu porque el senado de ese país
aprobó el paquete de 40.000 millones de
dólares para respaldar a ucrania con 86
votos a favor y tan sólo 11 en contra
los legisladores probaron una unidad que
pocas veces se ha visto en los proyectos
que ha propuesto el gobierno de joe
biden la semana pasada la cámara de
representantes le dio el aval a la ayuda
con 368 votos a favor y 57 en contra por
lo que el paquete ya está en pie más de
la mitad del dinero 24.000 millones
concretamente son para armar y equipar a
las fuerzas ucranianas nueve mil
millones para el gobierno de kiev y
cinco mil millones para ayudas
alimentarias a los países que dependen
de los cultivos que ucrania no ha podido
exportar
en relación con este tema el gobierno de
eeuu acusó a rusia de utilizar el
suministro de alimentos como arma de
guerra contra la población ucraniana
anthony blinken el secretario de estado
del país norteamericano presentó la
acusación ante el pleno del consejo de
seguridad de la onu klínger afirmó que
moscú tiene como rehenes el suministro
de alimentos de millones de ucranianos y
el secretario también le pidió a los
representantes rusos que levanten el
bloqueo de los puertos desde donde se
exporta el trigo ucraniano y los demás
granos y es que en conjunto rusia y
ucrania producen casi un tercio de todo
el trigo que se consume en el mundo
escuchemos a blick
y
la federación rusa afirma falsamente que
las sanciones de la comunidad
internacional son las culpables del
empeoramiento de la crisis alimentaria
mundial
las sanciones no están bloqueando los
puertos del mar negro atrapando barcos
llenos de alimentos y destruyendo las
carreteras y vías férreas de ucrania
sino rusia las sanciones no están
vaciando los silos de granos ucranianos
y el robo de equipos agrícolas
ucranianos rusia lo está haciendo las
sanciones no impiden que rusia exporta
alimentos y fertilizantes las sanciones
impuestas por estados unidos y muchos
otros países incluyen deliberadamente la
exclusión de alimentos fertilizantes y
semillas de rúsia
sin formación y comenzó la semana número
12 de la guerra en ucrania una de las
ciudades más golpeadas es mariupol allí
1730 militares ucranianos la mayoría del
batallón asof se han entregado a los
rusos según dice el ministerio de
defensa de rusia aunque varios
comandantes siguen resistiendo en la
planta de asos tal desdén y pro nuestra
enviada especial catalina gómez ángel
nos explica cuál es la importancia de
marie paule tiene un significado
diferente según cuál es el país que lo
mire para los rusos y especialmente para
el presidente vladimir putin podría ser
la única gran victoria que ha tenido en
estos tres meses de guerra pero a qué
costo al costo de una ciudad destruida
de cientos de personas muertas de
cadáveres en la calle de personas
viviendo totalmente en la miseria
atacando a las personas que intentaban
salir de allí y para los ucranianos si
bien esos 1.700 hombres que han salido
hasta hoy según dicen los rusos hombres
que defendieron a muerte su país están
en una especie de rendición o evacuación
como lo llaman los ucranianos también
ayudaron a crear ese sentimiento de
esperanza de lucha y de resistencia
ellos su lucha hizo que las fuerzas
rusas se enfocarán toda su lucha en ese
puerto sobre el mar de azov y
descuidarán de cierta manera esas otros
frentes como el área de kiev o por lo
menos que no pusieran allí todas sus
fuerzas lo que terminaría por el final
que las fuerzas rusas terminarán retirar
del norte del país y también de áreas
como jarquín eeuu y varios países
europeos han reportado casos de la
llamada viruela del mono pero declaró la
alerta sanitaria aunque todavía no ha
detectado ninguna infección aquí les
contamos de qué se trata este virus
la viruela del mono es una enfermedad
rara los síntomas incluyen una erupción
costras además de fiebre dolores
musculares ganglios linfáticos
inflamados escalofríos y agotamiento se
han registrado decenas de casos en
varios países europeos desde portugal y
españa- hasta suecia y reino unido se
trata de una enfermedad grave pero no
altamente infecciosa para los humanos
strange bing xing la cepa que se está
viendo en el actual brote en europa es
la cepa de áfrica occidental que tiene
una tasa de mortalidad de
aproximadamente 1 de cada 100 won en
sangre el departamento de salud pública
de massachusetts dice que ha confirmado
un caso en un hombre que viajó
recientemente a canadá
este paciente está ingresado en nuestro
programa especial de patógenos
actualmente se encuentra en condiciones
estables table kinder cement el paciente
se encuentra bien con seguridad en
aislamiento en nuestra unidad
actualmente no hay cura para la viruela
del mono está estrechamente relacionada
con la viruela que fue erradicada hace
décadas la vacuna contra la viruela
puede dar cierta protección
para understand y realmente necesitamos
entender mejor el alcance de la viruela
del mono en países endémicos como la
república democrática del congo y
nigeria la república centroafricana y
otros para entender realmente cuánto
está circulando y el riesgo que supone
para las personas que viven allí así
como el riesgo de exportación los casos
recientes en el reino unido- se
produjeron predominantemente entre
hombres que tienen relaciones sexuales
con hombres todavía no se ha determinado
si el inusual aumento de casos fuera de
áfrica indica un cambio en el virus o en
los medios de propagación y pasamos a
noticias de eeuu porque el estado de
oklahoma está a un paso de prohibir casi
todos los abortos los legisladores
aprobaron este jueves el proyecto de ley
que prohíbe la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo desde la fertilización es
decir desde el inicio sólo en casos de
emergencia médica de violación o de
incesto las mujeres pueden abortar
además se permiten las demandas contra
cualquier persona que ayude a
interrumpir un embarazo para que la
norma entre en vigor sólo falta la firma
del gobernador republicano kevin stick y
entonces será la prohibición del aborto
más restrictiva en todo eeuu
cerca de 37 años pasaron para que los
familiares de las víctimas de la masacre
de accomarca en perú recibirán los
restos de sus seres queridos en esa
matanza ocurrida el 14 de agosto de 1985
militares mataron a 71 personas de las
cuales 23 eran menores de edad los
uniformados los acusaron a todos
falsamente de pertenecer al grupo armado
sendero luminoso en 2016 los crímenes
perpetrados fueron reconocidos pero
quienes los cometieron aún siguen libres
les ha costado casi 40 años pero algunas
familias peruanas lograron recuperar los
restos de sus seres queridos víctimas de
la masacre de accomarca cuando en 1985
el ejército mató prácticamente a la
aldea entera tras acusarlos de
pertenecer al grupo terrorista sendero
luminoso con sus restos dentro de
pequeños ataúdes blancos' teófila ochoa
da el último adiós a su madre y a sus
cinco hermanos el dolor de tu corazón
jamás se va a borrar se va a doler si a
mi madre no me traería viva mis hermanos
a ese puede cortar pero no porque hay un
dolor por haber perdido mis familiares
sí que sé que he encontrado sí sí que lo
voy a enterrar sí pero las heridas nunca
se va a borrar porque está acá ella se
salvó al salir corriendo al campo pero
la mayoría de los habitantes de
accomarca no corrieron la misma suerte
cuando los militares dirigidos por el
subteniente telmo hurtado entraron en el
pueblo el 14 de agosto de 1985 y
asesinaron a sus habitantes
los 20 niños
ellos pensaron que los terroristas matan
ese tiempo a los niños niños niños
también nos respetaba le quitamos
traumados
cuantas veces
hasta el 2002 la justicia peruana no
comenzó a investigar la matanza para
después condenar a una decena de
militares como autores mediatos o
materiales del crimen ahora las familias
de los fallecidos planean darles
sepultura el viernes en la aldea rodeada
de pinos y eucaliptos con la intención
de cerrar ese capítulo horrible de sus
vidas
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
france24
[Música]